he's an American rapper record producer
and entrepreneur
he's the founder of aftermath
entertainment and Beats Electronics he
produced albums for and oversaw the
careers of many rappers including Snoop
Dogg 50 cent and Eminem he's dr. Dre and
hear his top 10 rules for success the
secret to my longevity I think is the
fact that I'm a perfectionist you know
and I listen to everybody you know I
mean even R&B I listen to classical
music some time I listen to have you mad
I'll just listen to everything you know
and really I listen to the wax more you
know because I want to know what not to
do you know the stuff that's not selling
you know it's easy to pick up a hit
record and know what people are buying
first of all you have to make sure that
this thing is for you and it's who you
are and you're built for this you know
and then you have to give it the passion
that's necessary you know like I said I
don't do it for the money the money is
gonna come I do it because of the love
that I have for it you know I'm saying
if I was a plumber or something like
that I still would make hip-hop records
that's how much love I have for it you
know I feel like right now I've been in
the game close to 27 years and I've
actually thought about this just
recently out of the entire 27 my 27 year
career there's only been two weeks
that I've been out of the studio there's
no I've never been out of studio longer
than two weeks in my entire career
that's how much love I have for this
thing that I do so that's the thing just
the passion that you have for it and
really really put your all into it and
make sure that your word is the last
word that way you don't you know you
don't play the blame game or anything
like that if it comes out hot it's on
you if it doesn't come out hot it's on
you you're I'm saying that's all it is
to it
craziest part about this revolution that
we started is this album Straight Outta
Compton was only done in six weeks five
days a week studio time you know I mean
at 3 hours a day you know so it was
crazy how this happened and it just let
me know how powerful I could be I'm like
if people are buying this wait till I
really get a chance to get in the studio
on some real equipment with some real
time what I think has to change for
people as far as on longevity is listen
looking at people that have made it in
the business you know Quincy Jones
people like that that's that's my mentor
right there because he's been he started
at a young age the same as I did and
he's still doing this thing and having
fun with it you know it ain't about who
has the flyest car who has the most
jewelry you know it ain't about that
it's about saving and preparing yourself
for when you're they happening no more
you know because it's going to happen
sooner or later
you know you just you never know when
you know when dr. Dre falls off if if
and when that happens I'm cool I'll
never have to touch another button as
long as I live straight up I'm cool you
know and that's what that's what you
have to think you have to say okay I
normal [ __ ] off some money so let me put
this money over here to [ __ ] off right
and let me save this let me save this
take care of your taxes take care of all
that you got to make sure you're
prepared when this dick what did you
hear in Eminem that made dr. Dre who we
know from NWA dr. Dre we know from
Compton you know saying dr. Dre that we
know from the chronic what made you hear
something in Eminem where you say man is
this Caucasian rapper out of Detroit
well first of all I didn't know he was
Caucasian whenever we yeah when I heard
it the first time I just loved the
delivery I loved his concepts and what
he was talking about cuz it was just
crazy you know what I mean
I found out a couple of days later that
he was a white cat you know man so then
I'm like wow I gotta meet him I gotta
meet him you know this is amazing and
everybody around me at that time we're
trying to talk was trying to talk me out
of working with him you know I mean
every single person around me was like
listen man this is a white boy you're
getting ready to ruin your career right
when we get that right when we get the
label started because that was at the
beginning of aftermath you know right so
um I just had to go with my gut I'm like
he's that hot people look people are
gonna get into it because it's that good
I don't ever feel the responsibility to
impress people with with my music I do
feel like I gotta get in and do do my
music to the best of my ability you know
and I feel like I'm my worst critic you
know if if I'm not digging it it ain't
just you know so the critics out there
can basically like kiss my ass straight
up because they know nothing about what
goes into this they're just people with
a nine-to-five behind a typewriter and a
CD player
listening to it and critiquing it you
know you can't criticize something that
somebody is working real hard on because
that can like shattered a hole you know
it might be a hit record in them you
know that's why I like it I'll be
sitting in The Source magazine and I'm
critiquing records and you know nobody
can critique my unless you've done half
of the stuff that I've accomplished you
know I'm saying nobody can critique this
you know there's nothing saying I'm
gonna make a smash every time I go in
the studio that's what I set out to do
but like I said before you don't know
what the public is gonna dig so all the
critics just need to shut the [ __ ] up
until they do or try to do that they're
criticizing it what's your process
before we get to hear a track you know
it's um it's not the same thing every
time it really depends on who I'm
working with I try to get inside of the
head of the artists on working with and
the record has to be down I don't go
approach the artists and say okay this
is what this is the way I think your
record should be I just tried to make
what they're bringing better and just
add whatever they're bringing add my
thing to whatever they're bringing so I
just try to get into and get in touch
with the artists try to get in touch
with their personality and what they're
trying to do and try to just take that
too you know two levels unheard of you
know that's that's just my thing I just
there's no set foundation or no set way
of doing it I think people are limited
because they're very well influenced by
people that surround them or people
that's in the media you know you see
some money criticizing something you're
not gonna do that
you know I'm saying I don't think like
that
do what I like straight up and a lot of
people have tunnel vision like you may
see people talking about how if they get
a lot of money or something like that
they're gonna stay in the ghetto you
want to stay in the projects that means
if you're standing there you're gonna
allow your mother and your family to
stay there also and I suppose straight
up you know the the change has to happen
somewhere and you're somewhere in your
generation you know I'm for my family
I'm saving money and I want my kids to
start on another level I want them to
start in the projects no that means they
have to build for their families if they
started at a higher level you know their
families are going to get better that
means your generation down the line
they're gonna have a foundation you know
and I'm gonna set the foundation
straight up get out your eyes on the
prize you know I'm saying tell you
somethin ain't nuttin on this planet I
can do yeah that's how I feel and that's
why I'm gonna stay at the level I am you
know I am on top of everybody if not the
one of the best producers in the world
period just know your business and know
what you're getting into before you get
into it straight out because this is a
doggy-dog world straight up in record
business
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because a lot of you guys
were asking for dr. Dre so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of dr. Dre's
top 10 rules meant the most to you let
me know leave it in the comments I'm
gonna join the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon